I just want to say that the Blues
Traveler is our band this year these
guys are real good guys hey Howard you
know what you should know John's been on
the show before yeah the guy's gonna do
a song or what yeah in fact you know
what you should know about the bad
Howard they've been on tour for like 18
months yeah I know what do you guys
double triple quadruple platinum
something like that um yeah we just got
nominated for Grammy - she's got
nominated for Grammy no kidding
you guys are real good live performers
you want to perform something now what
you gonna do yes it will do our hook
excellent
Blues Traveler everyone here at the
birthday so
[Music]
now let's see
the nature feel
[Music]
don't matter
[Music]
the showers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
there is something miss
[Music]
I
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to my car
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he never let us win over us you win and
then began to see watch it's what I mean
attempt it is now if I bring it so buddy
is killing me
[Music]
good
it's got a catchy little tune
[Music]
Hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I could listen to that all day
so good man that was great